nvidia just showed off their 30 series
in their reveal stream
the stream of many spatulas but more
importantly many cards we're going to
take
a quick look at each card the 70 the 80
and 90
and try and work out which one is right
for you i'm joined by michael heim
resident other graphics card nerd we're
gonna chat about
teraflops frames
other buzzwords that you hear a lot in
these streams ray tracing get excited i
love a bit of ray tracing me
yeah hey so the first first one
the cheapest of the bunch the 30-70 but
by no means is the cheapest of the bunch
any less powerful the stats that we were
seeing showing off
were a little bit silly considering the
price point
uh these cards are definitely being
forged by like old wizard blacksmiths at
some point
it's a hell of a jump and they are not
understating that at all i think they're
saying it's the biggest
performance jump in any generation
and they're they're really not wrong
faster than a 2880ti
a card that is now i mean the prices are
now going to plummet obviously
but time recording a 28 ti is twice the
price
of a 37 t yeah yeah the the so the rtx
3070
is the 500 option that they're offering
for the new
for the new generation and the claim is
obviously like you said
that it's faster than a 2080 ti and
that's huge
um all things considered so this is
based on the ampere
architecture which is the the evolution
of the
previous turing architecture it's kind
of the same thing
same build i guess with the multi-core
processing with
rt cores taking care of ray tracing the
tensor cores taking care of dlss and ai
based
tasks and then obviously the the main
streaming multiprocessor core is way
more powerful which is
why you end up with a 30 70 sort of mid
to high tier option
that's more powerful than what we have
currently at the high end
um so that's that's really impressive
and the thing is also
nvidia makes these claims um but they
don't
they tend to be fairly accurate uh and
as we'll talk about when
we go to the 3080 which digital foundry
actually got a hands-on preview with
uh these claims are pretty close to uh
to what
what's actual in reality so you know
this is it's pretty wild that you're
gonna get this level of performance for
that much money and it makes uh you know
i think we'll talk about this a little
bit more but you know ray tracing now
is a lot more prevalent than it was when
the rtx 20 series came out
uh and then now is the time to kind of
if you want to jump into that
the the market's there the games are
doing it the cards are powerful enough
to take care of this like
it's nothing so uh you know having this
much power at this price point is
impressive and it's exciting yeah
definitely the
looking back at like the 20 series when
ray tracing was announced it's like uh
how many games really can actually take
advantage of this but now like i said
it's everywhere you are going to have to
however wait
an extra month if you want to save a few
bucks
that's not the hugest deal but their
flagship card
always middle of the road always the one
that they push hardest the
3080 that i think is going to be
the one that a lot of folks are going to
try and get their hands on
regardless of how thin the supplies are
likely going to be
but with still like even better
performance
twice the performance of 2080 funnily
enough one of the things i was most
excited about
was the cooling and how quiet it was
because oh boy
the cards in my rig right now they're
noisy
yeah they they can get hot and then
those fins those fans can
spin up uh pretty fast make some noise
but uh yeah
like um you're not just getting a lot
more performance there's a lot of things
around the edges that are going to make
these cards better
but if we're talking about the 3080 and
the performance that
it's offering so as i mentioned earlier
this is what digital foundry was able to
test in a preview they weren't able to
put out
solid numbers because i'm base i'm
guessing that's based on embargoes and
all that
but they did relative performance
comparisons to the 2080 to see if it is
actually twice as fast so they played
games like control
doom eternal metro exodus and they were
getting
around 70 to 90 performance boosts
based on the 2080 the base rtx
2080 as compared to the rtx
3080. so that the nvidia's claim of
being twice as powerful
it's almost like it's pretty accurate uh
there also
of course it depends on the situation
but that that is a huge
performance jump and nvidia's claiming
that this is the biggest
uh like you said the biggest jump in
performance between generations
it's looking like that is also true now
the
the 3080 is going to be your card if you
want to if you're aiming for 4k
60fps uh the current rtx 2080 and 2080
ti
can do that with some compromises uh
native 4k uh if that's what your aim is
but this is a solid car that's
definitely going to be able to
to hit that that performance if that's
what you're looking for
at 700 uh of course that's that's the
higher end option
and that's kind of what you expect to
pay but the the jump between generations
is
it's it's pretty wild yeah definitely
and i think
there's still a lot of people out there
that see trying to get their rigs
to to play games in 4k as a little bit
of it it seems a little bit scary
sometimes you're a little bit of a
challenge but now
knowing how much power is behind the
ampere architecture
and just the raw performance that we're
seeing i think it
4k is now going to be much more
accessible
to pc gamers but what 4k
isn't enough what if you want eight okay
what if you want a silly amount
a resolution that they can't even show
off on stream
what if that's that's the kind of thing
that you know
floats your boat too many k's out there
now
oh man so yeah the nvidia always likes
to hit you with the wild flecks
and that's what they did with the rtx
3090 uh jedson wong pulled that out of
his oven
uh showed off this beastly card but it
smells delicious
oh man
come here i bet it's cake you cut into
that thing it's actually a
slice of cake this thing is huge it's
physically huge
it's also 1500 so this is not something
that most people are going to going to
even consider this is like the
enthusiast level
if you got way too much money to blow um
you know hey we always say eat the rich
so if you're going to buy this i'm
looking out for you
uh
but yeah it's pretty wild this is this
is their flex and they're claiming 8k
60fps of course there's no real way to
you know
test out which situations can actually
do that uh
if that claim is true enough uh but i
mean hey
if they're gonna put out a 1500 card and
that's what they're claiming
you know uh that's you know you could
probably at least pull that off in most
situations
but the thing is like of course like not
many people are even thinking or doing
8k at the moment
or probably won't be in the near future
so this is definitely something that you
know
if you're if you're about that life fine
go ahead but
this is that's the 30 90 is just kind of
that it's like the
titan rtx and then the titan xp before
that uh it's just that that ridiculously
powerful card
uh but i mean the fact that they're able
to do that uh is
it's pretty wild and it kind of kind of
tells you what what
nvidia has in store with their graphics
architectures and the graphics cards
that they're putting out
it's the card you list on your tinder
bio to try and get more dates
i'm ready i'm running a 3090 swipe right
i'll show you 8k baby oh my god how has
that has that worked well or
report back to me if i'm running i'm
running a's so
no one's swiping right mate i hate to
see it
but when when he showed that thing off
and the size and the scale of it i
thought
i was scared for the rest of my machine
honestly that thing
that thing's gonna fall down and i'm
gonna take something with it
like that might i'm gonna need a new
case it's not gonna fit in this case
and that's the thing with these big flex
cards is that it's not only 1500 bucks
for the card
you're probably also going to have to
spend some more cash
on making the most of
that gpu because my monitor can do 4k
what's the point of me buying an 8k card
i'm gonna have to buy
a new monitor knew this knew that it's
like you said
it's big flex time but the thing that
unites all these cards is some of the
really exciting stuff that's available
just in the new generation
we were chatting earlier and i think
that they've made a really
interesting and conscious decision to
not only have a card that looks better
but a card that feels better and makes
experiences better
with things like nvidia broadcast gonna
be real nice for streamers omniverse
machinimas
like a very niche thing but i think
that's super cool
but something that i think a lot of
people that invest in these cards are
going to feel
is the nvidia reflex gamers are going to
make this connection where they get this
new card
and automatically or with a little more
help they're hitting
their balance shots their battlefield
shots their cs go shots
it's going to be a piece of machinery
that they're going to think oh this is
actually making me
a better gamer so the suite of other
tech that's coming
with the raw performance as well is
something
to be equally excited for i think how
they're making the most
with ai and all the ray tracing
developments with
games that aren't even out yet it's it's
a real
interesting look forward as to where
nvidia's head
is at i think yeah it's like you're not
just getting a video card
you're getting a package uh of course
like i'm personally i'm only looking for
raw performance
and the ability to do ray tracing and
dlss
uh when games implement that but you're
also getting like rtx voice
and you're getting all these like the
broadcast streaming abilities that
you know take care of your framing for
you
with you with your own camera that
you're streaming from and
puts you into frame you can do different
backgrounds like the machinima stuff you
said the rtx i o stuff
is also really impressive for getting
the most out of your out of your storage
drives it's
there's there's so many things that are
going into this hdmi 2.1
uh is also across all the the new rtx
cards
so you can actually do 4k 120 fps
if you have that level of display and
these cards are likely to be able to
hit 120 frames per second in some cases
of course you would want to fiddle with
your settings and different things but
like
if you're also using dlss which is an
anti-aliasing thing that
is really wild to boost performance and
give you close to
if not the same image quality as native
4k
uh on top of that is it's like there's
it's a whole ecosystem that nvidia's
packaging with these cards
no matter what you're kind of looking
for out of it you know
the fact that they have 30 70 for the
mid-range the fact that they have the
3080 for someone who's looking for that
even higher end performance
twice of what we have now with an rdtx
2080. um
it's really it's it's uh yeah you're
getting a lot more than just
a powerful video card which is kind of
cool yeah and
um i think they're doing it a really
interesting time it's now in the same
conversation
as the xbox series x and the ps5 it
seems like they want to be
they want to say hey we're we're part of
the next generation of gaming as well
and with combining the price point of
the cards and
showing off stuff that's really
recognizable in gaming right now
both looking forward with cyberpunk and
call of duty as well as
obviously the household name of fortnite
it almost feels like they're making a
bid
towards the people that are unsure
if they want to start pc gaming if they
want to make the jump
to getting a pc and like
seeing the competitive price we still
don't know console prices
i think it's gonna sow some seeds of
doubt to people
that might have been saving up their
buckaroos for the new console and
thinking
maybe i'll maybe i'll make the jump to
keyboard and mouse maybe i'll
get a pc now and i think that's really
smart definitely on purpose because you
know
these folks they got the big brain
yeah it's um if you're thinking about
making the moves you should also
consider what you have now like for
example i have an rtx 2080.
i don't necessarily think that jumping
to a 3070 would get me
that big of a noticeable jump but i am
looking at the 3080 because that is
twice as powerful as what i have now if
you have anything below that
uh you know the 3070 is looking real
nice
you're getting a better than a 2080 ti
for 500 bucks that's wild to me uh and
of course it depends on availability
because uh these cards
if it launches during any normal time
they're still very hard to get
in their launch window yeah take into
consideration that manufacturing
processes have changed because of kova
19 and all that
so i'm not sure what availability is
going to look like but
if anything it might be harder to get
one of these cards around launch window
so take that into consideration as well
but just based on what we know about the
card so far from the reveal and digital
foundries preview
does it look like the rtx 30 series is
the is
is actually like very impressive yeah um
i mean our objective
is to get our greasy mitts on those
cards and show you guys
how impressive they really are as soon
as we have some hands-on
we'll try and get you some maybe some 8k
cyberpunk if
if if it's possible like i i um
oh yeah we're going to expense an ak
monitor yeah we can do that right
hey rob hook it up we're gonna
get our hands on every
card 70 80 90. and as soon as we've got
our greasy meds tonight we'll test them
not to death because i still want to
play with them but near to death
so we can tell you is it actually worth
it tell you our hands-on experience
so you're going to want to stay tuned
for that in the coming weeks and months
and if this stuff is getting you excited
and you are thinking of making the jump
to pc gaming heim and i have made a
video that's coming out
tomorrow talking all about the
everything you need to know for first
time pc builders
so maybe this time in a few months
you've built your first pc and you can
nerd out with us
when we're playing 8k 60 frames
cyberpunk oh boy just
just saying that brings a smile to my
face all right so that's
our first impressions after seeing the
nvidia stream of
many gpus and many spatulas are you
excited let us know in the comment
section below like i said we're going to
show you off
everything these cards can do in the
coming months so
to see all that make sure you subscribe
to gamespot
[Music]
you